[Music]
you know I have a million questions
after the fall finale yeah first of all
that cliffhanger what is gonna happen to
talk I can tease the fact that you'll
find out right away what happens to him
okay so it's not like we're gonna drag
it out and all that so you'll find out
right away were you surprised when you
read that yeah I was I was yeah you
never you know I'm like what are we all
of a sudden Game of Thrones where we're
just like we're killing off lead actors
on our show what's going on here but um
and then I sort of like it kept me up at
night to I'm thinking and if no one's
safe and no one's safe that this is up
but um but yeah it's a amazing
storytelling what is one thing that you
would love to see happen for the
characters you pushing anything in the
writers room you know what it's actually
all happening i'm not even just saying
that i know that sounds so like cliche
and like that's textbook but but it
actually is happening especially for my
character i cannot wait until we come
back and you all see like what's
happening with kevin yeah it's pretty
cool it's i did not see it coming at all
it's pretty cool how would you describe
it in like one emotion what will be
happening raw
you
[Music]